monsieur boutemane bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes en liberté mais en exil vous avez
des compatriotes qui mène la même lutte
que vous pour l'indépendance de la
catalogne qui sont en détention et
risque des années des années de prison à
partir
enfin à la suite d'un procès qui devrait
commencer la semaine prochaine
quel sentiment vous habite à ce moment
ci face à ces procès qui commence la
semaine prochaine
eh bien il faut dire que toulouse de son
concert de cette répression injuste de
l'état espagnol
notre devoir lorsque nous sommes des
citoyens européens
parfaitement livre tous les prophètes
d'un tout le monde sauf sont dans
l'espagne c'est de dormir la voie à tous
et qui celles qui ne peuvent pas
s'exprimer
ils sont emprisonnés depuis plus d'un an
sans avoir été jugé encore un badaud
s'exprimer en liberté et de dénoncer
cette situation inacceptable de
considérer comme des criminels des gens
comme commis de délits que nous avons
commis le délit de convoquer un
référendum pour l'autodétermination
l'allemagne n'a pas reconnu les crimes
qui sont reprochés à vos compatriotes
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous êtes
à nouveau en belgique et en liberté mais
en exil quand même est-ce à dire que
pour vous il ya on est en présence d'un
déni de justice
ici d'une part votre constitution
espagnole qui nie le droit à
l'autodétermination et de l'autre le
droit international qui reconnaît le
droit à l'autodétermination des peuples
oui il faut préciser que la constitution
espagnole ne rejette pas le droit à
l'autodétermination en fait elle ne la
reconnaît pas ce qu'il ya l'article 96
que dit clairement que tous les traités
internationaux qui sont signés par le
royaume de l'espagne font partie de
l'ordre interne de l'état et donc entre
ces accords internationaux il vient le
lait pacte international des droits
civils et politiques qui a été ratifié
par l'espagne l'année 1900 1977 qui dit
le premier
point tout le monde le connaît je
suppose à québec
tous les peuples ont le droit à
l'autodétermination donc le problème
c'est pas que l'espagne ne reconnaît les
droits mais qu'elle ne le respect et
c'est quand même quelque chose étonnante
le cadre de l'union européenne par
référendum puisse être parfaitement
légal dans le cadre écosse et dans les
cas de l'espagne soit un crime c'est par
là c'est incohérent dans le cadre de
cette union européenne qu on dit qu'on
doit avancer sur un vigneault politique
mais il y avait quand même un article la
constitution de 1978 qui dit que
l'espagne et indivisible et à cet égard
donc madre de déclarer illégal le
référendum est ce que le fait que vous
soyez en exil mais que d'autres de vos
compatriotes indépendantiste soit en
prison et risquent leur liberté pour
peut-être quelques décennies encore
c'est un lourd prix à payer selon vous
et bien sûr que je ne nourris le prix à
payer parce que c'est un prix injuste
personne ne doit être un prisonnier ni
jugés pour avoir obéi au monde adam
parlement légitime sur le parlement de
la catalogne qu'il ya une large majorité
a décidé de ne convoquer un référendum
est de donner la parole au peuple
comment c'est possible que ce qui est
parfaitement légal dans d autres pays
quand j'assiste dans le cadre même de
l'union européenne
elle était le royaume uni soit candélie
ondes de pire pays dans le code pénal
espagnol que peut entraîner plus de 150
en prison ça c'est absolument
inacceptable doit se rebeller contre ça
et de dénoncer que c'est pas acceptable
à l'écart une démocratie pleine
démocratie occidentale de voir des
situations de prisonniers politiques d
exil politique de persécution à liberté
d'expression vous voyez dernière à
bruxelles avec moi il ya un chanteur de
rap qui a été condamné plus de trois ans
et demi de prison pour ces lettres des
champions que sont contre la monarchie
espagnole
ça c'est pas acceptable donc ni
depuis trois jours mais très lourd mais
on doit continuer à se battre pour
terminer avec ça jusqu'où vous
personnellement êtes-vous prêt à aller
pour votre cause
retourner en espagne risquer la prison à
votre tour vous restez en exil en
belgique et battez vous mais moi je suis
refusé je suis était emprisonné en
allemagne mais il a justice allemagne
que c'est d'ailleurs venu jusqu'ici
indépendante du pouvoir politique a
décidé clairement il n'y a pas un délit
de rébellion que c'est d'un liberté
d'expression et donc je veux démontrer
que cette dérive qu'on nous accuse de
danse n'hésite pas non plus à l'espagne
c'est une construction fabuleuse
fantastique de pouvoir politique et e
jets dois continuer à me battre pour ça
il te parcourait l'europe voire le monde
pour continuer à m'exprimer à dire que
d'abord les catalans veulent exercer
leur droit à décider leur avenir comme
le reste du peuple du monde
et deuxièmement que l'espagne n'est pas
exactement une démocratie exemplaire
parce qu'elle ne peut être garantie des
droits à tous leurs citoyens
vous voulez l'indépendance vous l'avez
déclaré aussi tout en restant membre que
la catalogne les bras au fond
indépendante serait membre de l'union
européenne mais l'union européenne ne
reconnais pas les résultats du
référendum et donc ne reconnaît pas
votre démarche
comprenez vous pourquoi bon c'est dans
la tradition de l'union européenne être
pas le premier à reconnaître les
indépendances carrément on a vu qu est
ce qui s'est passé avec les ovnis ils
n'ont pas été pas du tout même si on n
était depuis concernés ils ont pas été
invités le premier à reconnaître
l'indépendance les ovnis donc d'abord il
ya les traditions européennes d'être
dans ses rangs six ans toujours en
retard par rapport au reste du monde
mais de seulement il un paradoxe parce
que l'union européenne
finalement elle accepte la realpolitik
et aujourd'hui les slovénie ce membre de
plein droit de l'union européenne et
donc oui c'est cet épisode la catalogne
indépendante vous
et toi rejoindre à continuer dans
l'union européenne
d'ailleurs parce que nous sommes des
constructeurs les country moins positif
au budget de l'union européenne mais une
puissance énorme un catalogue c'est
quand même incompréhensible que des
citoyens européens ils économique
parfaitement européenne des institutions
qui se sont organisés et puissent être
écartés de cadre de l'union européenne
si facilement parce qu'au fond la
catalogne est une région dite autonome
des catalans veulent l'indépendance et
se joindre à l'union européenne comme
l'espagne et dans l'union européenne
fait tout comprendre rapidement qu'est
ce que vous gagnez de plus à être
indépendant est bon on peut avoir d'un
moment les outils et les ressources pour
gérer le défi que nous de voir confronté
vous savez à catania c'est un pays avec
une économie puissante mais que doit
concourir avec des autres économies de
l'europe et elle reçoit pas du tout
les investissements pour améliorer les
infrastructures
on n'a pas apprécié après 40 ans de
constitution espagnole avoir respecté
notre landes
on ne peut pas parler un canard le
parlement espagnol par le parlement
européen où paie pas en fait
en pratique garantir le les droits
linguistiques des catalans ont des parts
recevoir les investissements père
capitale tous les ratios de capital par
rapport au reste de la région de
l'espagne 1 et après 40 ans de tout
essayé de améliorer notre autonomie de à
arriver à un accord fiscal à vis de
l'espagne et tout a échoué et que le
seul chemin pour continuer à être une
nation respectée et avoir la
souveraineté totale toi c'est le devenir
un état indépendant mais ce projet man
vous aller témoigner au procès de vos
compatriotes
il faut peut-être signé pour le
téléspectateur que parmi les
indépendantistes vous ne partagez pas
nécessairement les mêmes idées les mêmes
stratégies parmi eux il ya des dents ses
adversaires reste que ce sont des
compatriotes emprisonnés vous aller
témoigner
qu'allez-vous dire au tribunal
d'abord je vais témoigner jeu tous les
défenses ont présenté ma disposition à
témoigner mais le ou pour l'instant le
tribunal a rejeté la possibilité que
j'aime que moi je puisse déclarer c'est
quand même étonnant
ils veulent savoir la vérité et donc
pourquoi ils se rejettent que je puisse
au timonier dans ce procès et
deuxièmement malgré que les biens du
mouvement pour l'indépendance de la
catalogne
il ya des grands d'identité qui m'a
donné plus les libéraux jusque-là
anticapitaliste mais quand même
malgré tout ces divergences évidente il
ya une grande unité à faire face à
l'autoritarisme la méta mais ça montre
aussi que notre pour notre rôle en
politique c'est diverse plurielle
il n'appartient pas à une idéologie une
classe sociale
mais le contraire c'est une mélange des
genres de les grandes villes paysans les
gens qui sont de gauche et gestion de
droite donc ça montre justement la
puissance de ces mouvements parce qu'il
est énorme le courrier nouveau
gouvernement un espagne après le départ
de travail avez vous un certain espoir
de retrouver le dialogue vous vouliez au
lendemain du référendum avec un résultat
majoritaire malgré des problèmes
d'abstention de de suppression des votes
de fermetures de bureaux des votes de
répression policière et tout ça vous
vouliez suspendre la déclaration
unilatérale d'indépendance pour
dialoguer avec le gouvernement espagnol
ça n'est jamais venu est ce que le
dénouement de la situation passe encore
aujourd'hui par le dialogue
oui toujours il doit y aura bialo moi je
fais quelque chose
brémond douloureuse pour moi mais
nécessaire d'ailleurs ce que ces deux
s'ils avaient la possibilité d'ouvrir
une fenêtre au dialogue de privilégier
cette priorité
malheureusement la réaction de l'état
était pire ils ont profité cette stop au
processus d'indépendance pour organiser
grave répression
malgré tout ça je on plaide moi je
plaide pour un dialogue politique
il faut pas oublier comme si et son chef
est devenu premier ministre de l'espagne
grâce à notre soutien
grâce à notre voie parce que sans eux
notre soutien il aurait pu par arriver
être premier ministre de l'espagne et
donc on attend
on attendait beaucoup de monsieur
centriste mais malheureusement après
quelques mois on a vu un changement de
vocabulaire ça c'est évident mais les
politiques sur lui-même et ses teintes
de être courageux et de dire moi je fais
face au peuple catalan de dire c'est le
moment de suspendre la déclaration pour
habiliter un processus de dialogue
et quant au procès ils vont ces procès
vont avoir lieu neuf de vos compatriotes
indépendantistes sont emprisonnés depuis
près de 18 mois
l'un d'entre eux monsieur bouchard a
déclaré que c'est le meilleur service
que nos adversaires peuvent rendre à
l'idée d'indépendance que ces procès ad
vous espoir qu'ils soient acquittés
libérer ou plutôt le désespoir pour vous
qu'il soit condamné à 15 20 et 25 en
prison moi je dois retenir l'espoir de
payzone être acquittée mais c'est pas
uniquement parce que ça serait une bonne
nouvelle pour nous et pour bien sûr nos
familles mais surtout aussi par
l'espagne parce qu'elle s'en montrait
que vraiment alors il y aurait vraiment
une séparation de pouvoirs et une
justice est juste et que parce qu'il
n'ya pas un crime de rébellion écouter à
l'espagnol je crois que dans la majorité
peuples du monde les crimes de rébellion
quand on traîne l'utilisation des armes
de la violence et tout le monde a pu
voir que notre engagement parfaitement
claire est la non violence au pacifisme
c'est clairement quelque chose offensive
de dire à des politiciens qui sont très
honnêtes qui sont des hommes de paix qui
ont agi face au parlement va recevoir à
puiser l'utilisation de la violence et
donc ça sert la citation ce serait aussi
une bonne nouvelle pour l'espagne
malheureusement si on doit être réaliste
on doit ça cadre le pire mais on doit
atteindre les pros
suse et finalement la sentence est ce
que ça vous inquiète monsieur putsch
avant de voir que l'europe
d'autres priorités que la catalogne et
le procès des prisonniers il ya le break
cite évidemment des conséquences pour
l'irlande les élections européennes
évidemment il ya des grands problèmes en
europe autre que livre parce que ça vous
inquiète une sorte d'indifférence lors
que nos citoyens européens
je suis énormément dessus pas de manque
de soutien processus d'indépendance de
la catho mais parce que c'était très
variable ça mais surtout de lessines ans
complice de ce recul démocratique qu'il
ya d'espagne c'est pas acceptable
décideurs de l'euro une façon de police
qui utilise la violence contre des
citoyens européens pacifique
c'est pas acceptable qui est de voir
dans une politique que l'union
européenne reste en silence
c'est ça que on parce que nokia recul
démocratique à l'europe
n'importe qui c'est la cua ou la pologne
ou en italie ça nous concerne tous et
c'est le devoir des institutions
européennes de privilégié de protéger la
carte européenne de droits fondamentaux
et donc c'était sait se taire
rester en silence lorsqu'un état
puissant comme l'espagne qui viole les
droits fondamentaux
c'est pas uniquement une déception comme
catalan c'est une déception comme
europen la team messieurs pullman merci
beaucoup de votre participation à 24,60
et bien sûr nous allons suivre
l'évolution de la situation dans les
prochains jours prochaines semaines
merci beaucoup merci